hey guys came here can fifa 15 predict
the future can i be playing football or
soccer games most of my life it all
started for me with football italia 90
you know the one who are a sliding
tackle made it look like you ran the guy
over with a bus but today FIFA is
arguably king of football or soccer
games for me anyway I used to be a PES
guide for the record but ea's franchise
has won me back and in some ways this
game is almost as much of a simulation
as a game the sheer amount of data and
the thing is incredible player skill for
morale referees stadiums managers the
list goes on almost every aspect of real
football is recreated and plays a role
in each game so then could we use FIFA
15 as a simulation and predict football
results included perhaps outperform boot
makers and maybe even professional
pundits
now okay you might be thinking cam this
has been done before and you wouldn't be
wrong but you also wouldn't be right you
see while other game sites have used
previous FIFA titles to simulate the
world cup for example and make
predictions which is cool no one has
really analyzed them and answered the
key question of exactly how good is FIFA
at making these predictions so to do
this I decided to simulate the first 50
games of the 2014-2015 English Premier
League season in FIFA 15 but how to do
this well there was no point in getting
humans to play because obviously the
skill level of each player would have
way too much impact on the match results
so i took the people out of the equation
and set the computer against itself for
50 games and recorded the results making
notes of whether it was a win for Team a
a win for Team B or a draw now that we
have our data from those 50 matches it's
time to compare that with the results
from the real-life games and work out
whether or not FIFA is better or worse
at predicting than random chance
because there is only three possible
outcomes for each game random chance
alone should be able to get it right
around a third of the time or 33.3
percent now in our sample size of 50
games that means the target for FIFA 15
to beat is 17 correct results so how did
FIFA do well out of the 50 matches
played it actually predicted 22 results
which is better than random chassis
score of 17 but hold on there let's not
celebrate just yet sure it wins this
matchup but does it win by enough 22 is
only five more than 17 after all so we
need to work out if this win is
statistically significant no wait don't
go I know I mentioned the S word but
please let me explain and it's really
quite interesting so let's imagine we're
gonna roll a standard dice to predict
the result of each game let's assign one
and two to a team a victory three and
four to A Team B victory and five and
six to a draw if we enrolled for all 50
games we wouldn't necessarily get
exactly 17 correct we'd probably score
something close to that but he'll it's
technically possible although incredibly
unlikely to get every result correct
just by rolling a dice and getting lucky
so what we need to do then is calculate
how likely it is that our 22 results
from FIFA were actually down to just
luck
okay time to grab a calculator and see
if this guy can remember any of his
university stats course he did over 10
years ago half the battle when working
these things out is deciding which test
to actually do now I opted for one
called a binomial probability test
because our FIFA results are either
correct or incorrect our results are
actually binary if you just as easily
express them as a one or a zero let's
work this out i used a great website
called stattrak which is just wow set
phasers to far all i had to do is plug
in the numbers our probability of
success by guessing is thirty-three
percent or point three three our number
of trials is 50 on our successes is 22
this gives us a probability of 0.03
which is significant another way of
saying this actually is that there's a
three percent chance the FIFA's correct
results are just down to luck and that's
pretty small so well done FIFA now you
can celebrate
now I'm not a gambling man but I did
gather together bookies predictions for
the first 50 games of the season using a
site called odds portal it's an odds
aggregator of sorts and works out the
average odds for a number of rookies in
this case around 14 so how did the
bookies fare well not great actually
they only scored 19 which statistically
is no better than random chance so that
means FIFA 15 is actually a better
predictor of results than the average of
good makers however there are a few
caveats here in the 50 games i tested
not once did the average bookmaker score
predict a draw what you've got to
remember is that while bookies are
giving a rough prediction with their
odds they are also trying to encourage
people to bet money so there is a
financial incentive to the odds they put
forward it's not just a straight-up
prediction but still another victory for
FIFA 15
okay finally what about professional
pundits people whose job it is to know
football and predict results accurately
well perhaps the best-known pundit in
the UK is the BBC's Mark Lawrenson so
can FIFA 15 best laurels predictions
well based on the same 50 games Laurel
comes in with an impressive score of 27
correct predictions that's fifty four
percent against FIFA's forty four
percent sorry FIFA you've clearly been
outdone by the old pro
let me know what you think of this and
anything it's all about this episode in
the comments down below or by getting in
touch with me on twitter at Camp fraz
Rob also next week I'm thinking about
putting my money where FIFA's mouth is
and seeing if I would have actually made
cash box at the bookies if I'd let fever
dictate my betting choices over those 50
games let me know if you want to see
that in next week's reality check oh and
a little disclaimer now I think I did
the stats part right but I'm not a
statistician i can barely say the word
but if you are and you have any pro tips
or corrections please do let me know in
the comments alright thanks for watching
guys see you next week
you